the union uniform that represents the
workers working in the Alberta tar sands
we're told are the ones who want all the
pipelines being built they're saying you
know what instead of just fighting to
protect those Wendling few dirty jobs
we're ready to band together and demand
a leak to the next economy in renewable
energy in public transit and energy
efficiency this message is coming loud
and clear now from a Catholic Church
from a lot of faith organization this is
a moral responsibility it has to be part
of your faith to protect the gifts of
creation you don't have to choose
between climate action and having a
strong economy we actually can have a
fair economy or tasting economy a more
humane economy and one that lowers
emissions dramatically but we have to
have vision and we have to have courage
we are dealing with political leaders
who are will be gathering at the UN